breaking news from Politico a major
Scandal involving the new Republican
Speaker of the House Mike Johnson
they've got him now the walls are
closing in it turns out according to
politico's crack team of reporters that
speaker
Johnson sits on the board of a Christian
Publishing House called Living Waters
Publications the CEO of which is a man
named Ray Comfort who once narrated a
video which suggested that there is a
link between monkey pox and weird sex
stuff among the fellas which which is
true obviously uh but also the speaker's
office says this is not a reflection of
his
views the wall they've got him now the
walls are closing
in that's that's actually the attack I'm
not you you might think I'm mocking it
or being hyper that's that's the attack
that's the big breaking
news this
attack is so weak that that even the
other lib Outlets are just ignoring it
it's just a total
flop if anything the only reason I
mention it it speaks pretty well of the
new speaker in that if this is the best
that his opponents have on him then
speaker Johnson must be the cleanest man
in the United States I'm Michael NES
this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show this
episode's brought to you by good
ranchers claim your year of free meat 15
bucks off and free free shipping with my
code nolles kwes at goodranchers.com
that is goodranchers.com promo code
nolles
today crazy crazy tension and fighting
going on last
night in Washington DC the Capitol
Police triy to Wrangle Pro Palestine
protesters outside of the DNC
headquarters we'll get to that in just a
moment first though I don't want to move
off Mike Johnson Too Quickly this guy
seems great he seems so great he just
States basic truths bluntly he doesn't
shy away from them he's extremely
socially conservative he goes on at
CNBC and was asked about the sacred
American separation of church and state
and he gives a perfect answer there is a
question about the separation of of
church and state uh we often talk on
this show about uh folks uh about
whether religion should play a role uh
inside a company whether people should
be allowed to to pray inside a company
there's one thing to to pray outside and
to have your faith and and and there's a
great importance in that but how do you
think about that and how do you think
about the public perception of that okay
put a pause right
there buddy spit it out what are you
talking about the question is what do
you think about the separation of church
and state but he opens up he goes and
there's a question it's not for me
necessarily it's there's a question
critics say a lot of people are asking
many people are talking about it that
there people can have religion but
should they have should they be able to
have religion in public or should it cuz
you can have religion in private I guess
is maybe okay in some cases unless you
think bad things and that I disagree
with and and but can you are you allowed
to have those beliefs and do the things
and like even maybe pray possibly and
once you leave your home a lot of people
are talking about what do you what do
you think what do you think about that
so he finally spits out some vague
semblance of a question and then there's
Mike Johnson in the batter box here
knocks it out of the park listen
faith our deep religious Heritage and
tradition is a big part of what it means
to be an American when the founders set
this system up they wanted a vibrant
expression of faith in the Public Square
because they believe that a general
moral consensus and virtue was necessary
to maintain this Grand experiment in
self-governance that we created a
government of by and for the people we
don't have a king in charge we don't
have a middleman so we've got to keep
morality amongst us so that we have
accountability and so they they wanted
Faith to be a big part of that the
separation of church and state is a is a
misnomer people misunderstand it of
course it comes from a phrase that was
in a letter that Jefferson wrote it's
not in the Constitution and what he was
explaining is they did not want the
government to encroach upon the church
not that they didn't want principles of
Faith to have influence on our public
life it exactly the opposite Washington
said of all the dispositions and habits
which lead of political Prosperity
religion and morality are indispensable
supports and John Adams came next and he
said our constitution is made only for a
moral and religious people it is wholly
inadequate with the government of any
other but isn't it bad to
uh can you imagine that poor CNBC host
just
H and Mike Johnson there completely off
the cuff just gives a perfect summary of
the role of religion in public life and
the way that liberals have revised
history to pretend that we were founded
as some sort of atheist Nation or some
other such nonsense when our founding
fathers were extraordinarily clear about
the not only importance but the
necessity of public religion for our
government to work just rattles it right
off knocks that nonsense down this guy
is good it also shows you Mike Johnson
is a clearly a very intelligent and
educated man which is not always the
case in Congress I remember some years
ago a friend of mine was running for
congress and Tom Price came to the
district to do a fundraiser Tom Price
became the head of Health and Human
Services Under Trump uh before that he
was a member of Congress head of the
Republican study committee he was very
intelligent member of Congress and he
said to my friend he said you know I
don't know if you're going to like
Washington because the median IQ over
there in Congress is probably a couple
standard deviations below what you're
used to and I listen I like the members
of Congress some of my best friends are
in Congress but uh not always the
brightest bulbs in the pack over there
this guy is smart and he's educated and
he knows what he believes he's not one
of these blow-in thewi politicians and
he's willing to take the fight to the
libs even on contentious cultural social
issues really really good
stuff now is Mike Johnson the most
conservative politician in America no no
he's not because I think we would have
to give that title right now to xiin
Ping the Chinese Communist dictator came
to visit California specifically came to
visit San Francisco and chairman shei
with his very brief visit to San
Francisco has done more to clean up that
city than any politicians liberal or
conservative in other parts of the of
America seem to have done in decades San
Francisco absolute disaster druggies
criminals on the street shooting up
dying of exposure breaking into cars
wealthy people fleeing the city
burglaries vandalism all that she shows
up and right before he gets there all
the bums are gone the is cleaned up all
of the broken windows they're all fixed
and you could basically eat off the
sidewalks very very
impressive some conservative
commentators were dismayed at the
pictures from She's visit and I
understand why because the Streets of
San Francisco look like they're the
streets of Beijing they were just
Chinese red flags everywhere and it's a
little
spooky I don't think we want to become a
vassel state of China That's and I don't
want to I don't want it to seem like I'm
singing she's Praises just because the
Chinese Communists are better than
American liberals at many many things
that's damning with faint praise okay
I'm not saying that's
ideal but there are even some
conservative commentators who say look
at this these images from the Streets of
San Francisco and get ready that's what
America is going to look like soon
enough and the fact
is they're basically right about that it
sounds like one of those hyperbolic
conspiracy theorists you know
fear-mongering catastrophist lines get
pretty soon we're going to just turn
into communist China and chairman she's
going to be ruling us with an iron fist
but what what is going to happen what's
going to happen there there at the
present trajectory of American Decline
and Chinese Ascent two things can happen
the most likely thing is that we're
going to have a global war
because most of the time as the Harvard
political scientist Graham Allison has
showed
when Rising Powers confront great Powers
three qus of the time in recent history
that has led to a major conflict a war
so likely that's what's going to happen
and then the question is can the United
States win a war right now can we fight
a war I'm not convinced that we can
we're extremely divided the libs have
turned our military into a critical race
Theory uh
[Music]
sexual identity struggle session so I
don't know that that's a great idea the
American people are extraordinarily
divided even on basic first principles
and we bogged down in all sorts of Wars
of Empire around the world that don't
directly affect our our Vital national
interests so if some of our Vital
interests were threatened Say by a
rising China we would probably be
scrambling to do anything about it also
our military was degraded over eight
years of Barack Obama and and certainly
neglect under Joe Biden so that that's
probably the first thing that would
happen but then even let's say we
somehow avoid war or or the war turns
out fine in the
end what will happen is if China manages
to keep on its path and if America
doesn't reverse the decline that
decadence and liberalism have put us in
then China will be a global power we'll
have a first a multi-polar world with
the United States and China as two of
the great powers and then you know
Empires are born and they rise and they
fall if
America we hope it doesn't happen but if
America does really decline then we will
be subject to the same kind of cultural
imperialism that we have subjected the
rest of the world
to and that's not good uh we don't want
that I I don't want red Chinese flags
anywhere in the United States other than
for a few days to clean up the city of
San Francisco but that's not something I
look forward to well if that's not
something you look forward to if you
don't look forward to decline if you
don't look forward to to cultural
imperialism and outright Invasion when
you don't have any borders then you have
to support an agenda that will make
America great again then you have to
support an agenda not just of small
government not just
of global liberalism and and running
every single country around the world
you have to support an agenda that is
specifically oriented toward National
greatness in the United States and very
few people seem willing to do that now
one way to begin is around the kitchen
table Ronald Reagan said all good
politics begin around the kitchen table
and when you want greatness on your
kitchen table you got to check out good
ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use promo code nolles
there's a lot at stake this November so
don't be chicken and shop at the grocery
store like usual instead you should see
food n no that one I added that one in
there go get good ranchers it's it's
great it's even even better than my meat
puns head on over and do not miss their
Black Friday yourway sale which is now
live this November get your favorite
meat free for a year that's right one
year of free steak salmon chicken or
bacon when you subscribe to any box
right now better yet when you subscribe
to any box on goodranchers.com you not
only get a free gift of meat up to 480
bucks you also get $15 off with code
noes I don't know how they do it the
meat is exceptionally high quality I
I've never seen anything like it I love
it I eat it multiple times a week when I
can I'm not being sent on the road and
kept away from my good ranchers I don't
know how they keep the prices so low I
don't know how the meat is All American
Meat I don't know how they're giving you
free meat for a year I don't know how
any of their finances work but their
financial confusion is your benefit go
get it right now it is I could not
possibly recommend good ranchers highly
enough go to goodranchers.com use code
NES your free meat 15 bucks off number
one place to get all American beef pork
chicken and seafood B promo code nolles
kwes good Ranchers .c good ranchers
American Meat delivered now turning to
more cities in disorder across the
country from San Francisco you have
Washington DC where a riot broke out
last night
because leftist
protesters were rioting outside of the
Democrat National Committee headquarters
so much so that the news is reporting
the DNC had to be evacuated by Capital
police so hold on here this wasn't the
January 6ers this wasn't the neo-nazis
and the wh well in a way we we'll get to
what they were protesting about this
wasn't the white supremacists this
wasn't the far right-wing blah blah blah
Charlottesville whatever these are Libs
these are the people who were protesting
outside of the DNC we are outside the
DNC we're outside the Democratic party
headquarters because this party claims
to be on the side of life and peace and
equality and we're saying that we want
them to live up to their values and
oppose this horrific war and call for a
ceasefire now and we're being responded
to by the police shoving anti-war
activists down the stairs shoving
peaceful protesters back with their
bikes and because our party our party
that 80% of us want a ceasefire would
rather beat up protesters hold on Super
One Second One Second One
Second oh my goodness howling like
animals
there's a lot of cops out there tussling
with a lot of protesters outside the
DNC this is an example of the phenomenon
you saw in the Iran Iraq war in which
Henry Kissinger famously said he wanted
them both to lose that's how I feel
about the DNC fighting the leftist
protesters what are they fighting over
they're fighting over the conflict in
The Holy Land of course because this war
in the holy land is a real wedge issue
for the Democrats the Democrat Elite the
Democrat establishment the Democrat
donors support the state of Israel by
and large the Democrat base opposes the
state of Israel and supports the
Palestine Liberation Movement by and
large and it's not even particularly
close it's the vast majority of of the
activist base is extremely anti-israel
prop Palestine and the vast majority of
the Democrat establishment donor class
is at least significantly pro-israel and
anti- Palestine Liberation which is why
I really don't have much to say about
that war which is G on for a very long
time and will continue to go on for a
very long
time for the the American political
order the key here is that Mike Johnson
is a genius for separating Israel
funding from Ukraine
funding the key to this I guess my whole
thesis today is that the new Republican
speaker is just extremely clever and and
is is doing a pretty good job despite
compromising with the Dems on certain
things and disappointing conservatives
in some ways this is really smart the
first thing that that Mike Johnson came
came down and said was we need to
support Israel and we need to get a bill
to fund Israel's military immediately
and a lot of conservatives said wait a
second you're supposed to be America
First wait a second how about we focus
on the economy or the Border or this or
that or the other thing but I read that
as a pretty clever move because there
was going to be military funding and
what the Biden Administration was
pushing for was just massive virtually
endless funding for the war in Ukraine
and the war in Israel and the war in
Taiwan and the war here and the war
there and by splitting those things off
you're putting the Democrats on he's
already done it putting the Democrats on
the record as being for or against the
state of Israel and either way the
Democrats vote they lose either the
Democrats irritate their country club
Buddies the establishment types and the
neck ties with the donor checks or they
irritate those lunatics screeching on
the street of Washington DC but they
need those lunatics to win the elections
because those lunatics make up a lot of
the voters now speaking of liberal
activism liberal activists who just
succeeded at passing a pro-abortion
ballot measure in
Ohio are trying to do the same thing in
Nebraska uh this this new ballot measure
is being supported by protect our rights
which is endorsed by groups like the
ACLU and all sorts of awful leftwing
organizations plan Parenthood Advocates
of Nebraska they're submitting a
petition to uh to the secretary of state
of Nebraska to enshrine the the supposed
right to kill your child in the Nebraska
Constitution bad
idea what do we do about it well what we
do about it is we need our own ballot
measures think about what happened in
Ohio everyone's ringing their their
hands about this and they're saying oh I
guess abortion is a losing issue for us
oh the squishes are saying the
Republicans need to ditch abortion and
the the conservative answer I think is
well hold on where was our ballot
proposition the conservative response I
think is hold on what did the Ohio
ballot measure say here's what it said
this is this is issue one in
Ohio a yes
Vote for This ballot
prop supported amending the Ohio
Constitution to provide a state
constitutional right to make and Carry
Out one's own reproductive decisions
including but not limited to decisions
about abortion and contraception and
fertility treatment and miscarriage care
and continuing pregnancy and it's all
this gobbledygook language with a bunch
of nonsense but abortion snuck right
there in the middle and and uh so people
voted for that because they're not
reading these things very closely and it
sounds like a vote for yes is a vote for
freedom and health and choice and
tradition
this was really well written by the libs
to confuse
people why didn't we have our own ballot
measure why can't we write the pro-life
ballot measure which uses all the same
kind of feel-good language but for
something that's actually good instead
of something that's evil like the
Liberals are doing I don't think this is
a failure of life I don't think this is
a failure of the American people who
have overnight become just evil Maniacs
who want to kill all the babies I think
this is a failure of conservative
organizers to be wise as serpents and
innocent as doves I think this is a
failure of the imagination of
conservative organizers to go out there
and get our own ballot props I also
think it's a failure of ambition because
the conservatives after roie Wade was
overruled they said okay we got it now
we got to be we got to play cool guys
let's play a real cool and we got what
we wanted but let's not push too hard on
abortion just yet no man that's not how
politics works you got to go with the
momentum when you've got
it that's not how politics works in in
politics Sometimes the best defense is a
good offense you're winning on the issue
of life keep pushing that's what we did
on the issue and it got us Virginia and
it got us Florida and it's it's gotten
us a whole lot of other elections since
then it it turned parents into a
conservative voting group because we
didn't just say okay well we we were
able to win a little bit and raise the
age at which you can quote unquote No we
said hey these weirdos are trying to
push a bunch of of weird propaganda and
sexual grooming and schools and we're
going to kick all of that out and and
we're going
to to just use a phrase off the top of
my head and we've been winning on it
ever since it's it's like when you try
to pick up a girl at a bar if you go and
you're kind of timid and you you say
well hi hello there lady no you don't
have to talk to me if you don't want to
but maybe would you like to maybe go get
a cup of coffee some up then you're the
girl's going to think you're a weirdo
and she's going to think you have
something to hide and she's going to
think that you're not very attractive
but but if you're
confident as conservatives ought to be
in what we believe because the things we
believe are true and good if you're just
confident and normal and you say yeah
killing babies is bad we're going to get
rid of it right we all agree cool
killing babies no good yeah all right
great and you put that on the ballot
you're going to do a lot better because
that's what the livs have done for
things they should not be confident
about that are false and evil now
speaking of medical care you got to go
check out Medishare right now go to
medishare.com as a dailywire listener
you are not just informed you are
engaged and handsome and pretty you
value freedom and personal
responsibility that's why you need to
check out Medishare Medishare is a
community- based approach to healthcare
that lines up with what you believe in
your views matter and Medishare allows
you to take your Healthcare dollars and
not use them for medical procedures that
don't line up with your beliefs
Medishare is the highest rated
Healthcare sharing Ministry with a
30-year proven track record it's not
health insurance it's a community of
400,000 Believers committed to caring
and sharing with with one another
members save up to 50% or more on their
monthly healthcare costs and member
satisfaction surveys show that they like
Meda share much more than health
insurance why because it works for a
limited time dailywire listeners will
receive a $150 gift card when they join
Medishare to find out more go to
medishare.com m
iel that is Medishare M
share.com terms and conditions apply
speaking of
babies Congress lady Yadira
caraveo yesterday was celebrating birth
control this was Tren this was one of
the things trending on Twitter
yesterday thanks birth control and this
woman I've never heard of this this
Congressman but she says by age 50 women
who had Early Access to contraceptives
earned 8% more per hour than those who
did not as a doctor as a woman as a
member of Congress I will always defend
the freedom to choose thanks birth
control I love this tweet I love it I
don't love contraception I think that's
very bad but I love this tweet
because this is the best argument
they've got and it's a terrible argument
this is the argument for contraception
the argument for contraception is
sacrifice your children so that you can
earn 8% more money making widgets at the
factory that'll be fulfilling you'll
love that that'll lead to a flourishing
life yeah yeah don't have
kids I I understand there are plenty of
conservatives who use contraception and
who think contraception is fine and I'm
just even pull yourself out for one
second and just think about what
contraception means socially Contra even
forget about the personal choice and if
you like it or if you feel that you've
benefited from it just pull yourself out
socially what it means is fewer
babies we in the United States have a
dying population we we don't replace
ourselves it's it's literally a dying
country there there are fewer Americans
every single year which is why we have
to replace those who are not being born
with mass migration so you got a dying
country with a with a dying western
civilization and then what does
contraception mean it means divorcing
sex from the purpose of sex from the
natural ends of sex which is procreation
which means what it means
decadent Behavior it means ignoring
consequences it means being more
promiscuous it means what is what is
being more promiscuous mean it means
more broken hearts it means more Meo
movement it means more uh using human
beings just as vessels for our own
pleasure rather than actually giving
fully of ourselves to another person in
holy matrimony through a love that's so
real that it actually creates another
person it means things go wrong if you
criticize
the sexual Revolution if if you are one
of the people who says man this stuff
has gone really crazy can you believe
what they're teaching kids in elementary
schools
now you got to ask yourself okay did
that pop out of thin air or did that
come from somewhere else well no it
obviously came from somewhere else this
crazy sexual Revolution didn't appear
overnight the agenda probably comes from
the radical LGBT agenda more broadly
which denies the difference between men
and women uh-huh that's right keep going
well and that was enshrined in the
redefinition of marriage which was a a
decision from the Supreme Court yep
totally agree keep going well I guess
the premise that men and women are
exactly the same and IND discernible and
and can substitute for one another I
guess that comes from well feminism uh
yeah it does feminism which says women
and men are pretty much the same and a
woman needs a man like a fish needs a
bicycle that's totally true where else
though where does the sexual Revolution
come from what was the single event that
upended sexual mores in behavior in the
United
States it was the Advent of
contraception and not just the Advent of
contraception as a as a scientific
discovery there have always been
technological means some more effective
some less effective for putting off
conceiving that's been true for all of
history we we flatter ourselves into
thinking that we we invent every
Everything Under the Sun but we don't a
lot of these things have have been
long-standing in history albe it perhaps
less effective in the past
the big change was not a technological
discovery of birth control the big
change was the cultural mainstreaming of
it and the
legal uh the legal enshrining of a
license in the
Constitution the the founding fathers
didn't think there was some sacred right
to artificial contraception
right the Supreme Court the liberal
Supreme Court in 1965 just invented that
supposed right out of whole cloth and
they said yeah in the Constitution
somewhere between the first and second
amendments I don't know it's written in
invisible Inc there is a right for
married couples but only married couples
to use
contraception and that was the rule that
was uh Griswald V Connecticut and where
was that right in the Constitution I
don't know no one's ever shown it to me
but that's what the judges said so I
guess there it is seven years later the
judges revisit the issue and they say
hey actually no we got it kind of wrong
um turns out between the second and the
third amendment somewhere in invisible
Inc is a
of unmarried couples to use condoms and
stuff too where is it I we'll show you
our work later but it's anyway it's in
there it's definitely and we should yeah
it wasn't we didn't get it totally right
in 65 but 72 yeah artificial
contraception then what happens the very
next
year abortion roie Wade is is dis
discovered in the Constitution the the
magical right to kill your kid that was
between the third and the fourth
amendments I guess in invisible L but
that's the that's the The Logical
consequence of it if people are having
what they perceive to be totally
consequence-free sex if people believe
that they have the right to an activity
without the natural consequence of that
activity then when the natural
consequence of that activity crops up as
of course it's going to do people have
to invent another supposed right to kill
that thing to do whatever they can do up
to an including murder to deny the
natural consequence of one's
actions so it's not it's not merely a
simple answer of oh you old fuddy
duddies you think there's a problem with
condoms it goes much much deeper it goes
much much deeper than that to an entire
way of viewing the human person and love
and marriage and the relationship
between men and women which is the
fundamental distinction and fundamental
relationship within the human
race and and this woman boils it down to
so that's the that's the conservative
argument of why we ought to be a little
cautious when it comes to to
contraceptive methods the liberal
argument is yeah but you can make 8%
more at your widget job that's the
that's the best argument I'm not even
mocking this woman that is the single
best argument you can make
for mandating the right to contraception
everywhere in the world is yeah but if
you if you have kids you might not work
as much at the widget Factory this is
secular liberalism this is Mammon
worship this is all that matters is
ticking up GDP and bringing home a
slight larger paycheck and having dual
income and no
kids ah yes in my old age I'll be so
comforted by the extra 8% that I made at
my widget job no I don't think so I
don't think anyone has ever said that
but that's why this kind of secular
liberalism is collapsing and it's why
what what it is giving way to is a
serious conservatism a cultural and a
social conservatism now represented even
in the Speaker of the House of
Representatives we haven't seen that
maybe ever and and on the left it's
giving way to a a more radical and
aggressive but in some ways a more
serious form of political activism it
says no life isn't totally about money
it's about and then they come up with
their own cockamamy answers it's about
my identity it's my my racial Essence
it's about my gender fluidity it's about
but what they're talking about are still
things that are essentially
immaterial it's about my loyalty to this
group or to that group
the the shallow materialism of uh
sacrifice your kids to make 8% more in
your widget
paycheck that is not going to speak to
the ultimate longings of the human soul
so then the question is which direction
are we going to go in the radical left
direction that tears the whole country
to the ground or the conservative
Direction which says no we actually have
things that bind us together and we have
responsibilities toward one another and
we shouldn't just use each other as as
uh economic vessels to to to exploit or
as sexual vessels to exploit for our own
selfish interests but as fellow citizens
with a common interest and a common
country and a common
good now speaking of babies you know I'm
very Pro baby and babies are great and
they drive you crazy sometimes because
they're up screaming at night and they
agid you prematurely and they you know
uh can really wear you down but they're
also the the most gratifying thing out
there you know you any ask anyone ask
any parent what what is your greatest
accomplishment they're not going to say
the promotion I got at the widget
Factory they're going to say oh my kids
but increasingly people are replacing
children with pets and they say well
look my I'm a I'm
a dog mom or something and people would
say I'm a dog
grandma and this is this is very sad and
I don't mean to mock people for it or
even attack people for it we live in a
really messed up culture where it's hard
to find a husband and it's hard to have
kids and because our culture has lied to
us and told women to put off having kids
until they're 62 then they discover they
can't have kids and it leads to a a a
deep crisis and a great deal of sadness
so and and also they're pumping the food
and every and and the people full of so
many chemicals that infertility is on
the rise so I I have a great deal of of
sympathy for people who are dealing with
all of
that the answer to those issues is not
going to be to project your natural
longing for a child unto a puppy
or onto a kitten or something like that
the the answer to that is to be a a
mother or a father in some kind of
way not everyone can have kids even
adoption is not for everybody but you
should Endeavor to be involved with
human beings Matt made a great point on
one of the last backstages he said not
everyone's called to be literally a
mother or a father but you can at least
be a kind of spiritual mother or father
obviously people in religious life are
that they for go having biological
children and and they have spiritual
children and they you even call them
Father if you if you go to a more
traditional style church or Catholic
Church um you could be a God parent
there are plenty of wonderful God
Parents out there who don't they don't
have kids of their own but they have a
kind of spiritual Parenthood for other
people but increasingly what people are
doing is they're saying no I'm just
going to have a dog and I'm going to
treat my dog like a kid and I'm going to
spend more money on my dog than I would
sending my kid to
Harvard but there's a new study out and
you know I think studies are fake but
when they back up my points I'm willing
to cite them the study shows that having
pets does not really bring happiness and
it doesn't even really improve people's
well-being uh this study out of Michigan
State
University assessed uh 767 people on
three separate occasions in May 2020 so
specifically looking during Co when
people are locked up and you know we
were told that having a pet having any
life around was going to be really
really helpful and it just didn't do it
the data sets showed no difference in
the well-being of pet owners and non-pet
owners over time as William chopek an
associate professor in msu's Psych
Department co-author of the study he
says people say that pets make them
happy but when we actually measure
happiness that doesn't appear to be the
case people see friends as lonely or
wanting companionship and they recommend
getting pets uh it's unlikely that that
will be as transformative as people
think and this is really important again
I'm skeptical of the entire University
system of psychology Departments of
studies broadly yeah I'm skeptical of
all and even the notion that you can
measure happiness
but this Rings true to me because human
beings are different from animals it's
it's one of these same lies of
liberalism which tells us that we're
actually no different from monkeys or
dogs or the Delta smelt or a rock or a
tree we're all just bags of chemicals
man and and human beings aren't special
that's a very liberal view the
traditional view is that man is made in
the image and likeness of God and we
enjoy the creation we are stewards of
the creation though and we are quite
different from the animals and the rest
of creation so what we need to do is be
involved with human beings the left
being
misanthropic isues this idea and says no
no you don't need people people are
terrible forget about that we actually
need to stop having children we need to
kill old people we need to kill sick
people we need to kill babies when they
are conceived and we don't like them we
need to we need to just go worship
Mother Nature people are
bad uh but the conservatives too the
conservatives for many decades have said
well actually uh selfishness is a virtue
and we should just go out there and make
a lot of money and we can limit family
sizes and we shouldn't I don't need to
worry about my fellow man and you do you
and I'll do me and just don't bother me
and don't make me pay for anything and
both are just not they're just not true
that's not how human beings actually
work we are the social creature we're
the political animal we need one another
and there there's no substitute for that
you're not going to substitute that for
material possessions you're not going to
substitute that with robots or Ai and
you're not going to substitute that with
a little puppy you need people so why I
always say people say are you a cat
person or a dog person I say baby I'm a
people
person speaking of people my favorite
comment yesterday is from
s quite a name wow who says like Dan
banino says America's not an airp rep
you don't need to announce you're
leaving just leave that's a good line
Dan has very good lines that's a good
line that the libs always threaten to
leave Barbara stri now is saying I can't
I can't live in America if Trump is
president but lady you did you did and
you keep promising to leave and then you
don't make good on your promise Black
Friday sales are coming there is one in
particular that you need to know about
Harry's razor used to advertise right
here on our shows until I it was me I'll
take full
responsibility I was on Candace owens's
old show and I had the tarity to express
the view that boys are boys and girls
are girls Harry's then tried to cancel
me said that those views are inexcusable
they dropped their ads from my show and
from the daily wire broadly the list of
companies going woke continues to grow
have you had enough us too that's why
instead of complaining we created an
alternative Jeremy's razors and starting
Monday we will have the best deals of
the on all Jeremy's Razer products get
the alpha bundle for 40 40% off you can
also find amazing deals on the Precision
5 starter kit and the smooth six starter
kit there's something for everyone on
your holiday shopping list we've got the
famous he him and she her chocolate
along with some special Christmas
varieties that make excellent stocking
stuffers we've got hand soap deodorant
and an entire line of bath and beard
products all from a company that won't
insult your values stop giving your
money to woke corporations for Black
Friday shop Jeremy's razors instead with
these deals we are going to run out
quickly so don't wait start loading up
your C right now at Jeremy rises.com get
ready for our Black Friday deals
starting Monday speaking of human nature
and
happiness here's a here's a story that
might tickle the conspiracy theorists
among you you know those awful crazy
conspiracy theorists who are usually
almost always right about everything in
the last few years we say the difference
between a conspiracy theory and the
truth is 6 months but the conspiracy
theorists and the religious people and
the conserv AES
and Pope
Francis has just signed off on a new
document an official document from the
Vatican reaffirming that Catholics
cannot be
Freemasons what why can't Catholics be
Freemason wait hold on Pope Francis he's
supposed to be a big lib and a Kumbaya
and some people accuse him of being a
Freemason what do you mean Catholics
can't be Freemasons hold on the
Freemasons are still around I know
there's some old secret society that I
heard about in some movies but I I
they're that real and why does the
Vatican even care about
this there are all sorts of reasons the
Freemasons are a real group it's not
just something that comes out of
conspiracy theory YouTube videos uh the
Freemasons have largely been opposed to
the Catholic church in particular over
the centuries that part is true there
are lots of conspiracy theories about
the Freemasons some of those conspiracy
theories are true some of them seem
somewhat dubious to me but the reason
that Pope Francis is reaffirming the
consistent and traditional catholic
teaching that Catholics can't be
Freemasons is much more basic and it's a
lesson for all of us no matter what you
think your religion or political views
are the basic reason that Catholics
can't be Freemasons is because
Freemasonry is a sort of religion unto
itself that's the most basic reason
Freemasonry has its own particular
conception of God Freemasonry has its
own particular rights and rituals it
even has burial rights Freemasonry has
its own particular conception of mankind
and his role in the cosmos
viav God whether the Freemason would
call God God or use a different term to
refer to God it's just a different it's
just a different religion and you cannot
simultaneously be a member of two
contrary religions you cannot
simultaneously believe contradictory
things you cannot simultaneously serve
two Gods you can't do it I mean this has
been true since the origin the Advent of
Christianity and in fact since the
Advent of faith in the Old Testament
since since Abraham comes around and
says no we're going to give up all that
Pagan stuff because the true God my God
has told me that he is the one true God
and he's greater than all the other
gods you can't you can't do it I mean
goes back to to Aristotle's law of
non-contradiction you can't simultaneous
things that are simultaneous ly uh
pardon things that are mutually
contradictory cannot simultaneously be
true that's just a fact and a I think a
lot of people need to examine that
because people generally hold all sorts
of different views especially in a
pluralistic country many of which
conflict with one another so the
question you have to ask is what do you
ultimately believe where is your
ultimate devotion where does that
lie and in modern pluralist countries we
just try to push that question off and
we say no you can believe all sorts of
contradictory things and be sorts of all
part of groups just just don't think too
deeply about it but that's not possible
and even even a pope who many refer to
as a liberal is pointing that out of
course a story I I did want to get to
today Nikki Haley going after VI
ramaswami and a new poll out from New
Hampshire uh upending a lot of the
undercard race Trump is still as he is
pretty much everywhere just dominating
by a lot of points in the polls but the
undercard the number two number three
number four Place candidates they are
shifting around uh so I guess we're
going to have to get to that tomorrow
because today is theology Thursday and I
am extraordinarily honored to be joined
by one of the great living
theologians uh a friend of mine who I
was supposed to see in Nashville week or
two ago and daily wire unceremoniously
shipped me out of the country so I
couldn't see him but we will talk to him
now and a lot of you have requested that
he come on the show that would be Dr
Scott Han the rest of the show continues
now you do not want to miss it become a
member use code nolles KW L at checkout
for 2 months free on all annual
[Music]
plans